hey what is up guys I'm QB HD here and
welcome to my hotel room in San
Francisco California and I'm here
because I'm actually going to be going
to Google i/o which is just a couple of
days away it's right around the corner
around the corner literally but I'm not
doing a video about Google today I'm
actually doing a video about Apple today
so when you're out and about traveling
or even just wearing the Apple watch in
general no matter how much you cover it
up or no matter how much you don't show
it to anyone
people when they figure out that you're
wearing an Apple watch inevitably have a
lot of questions about it even if you're
wearing some other SmartWatch they ask
about the Apple watch so I have sort of
compiled a list of the ten most
frequently asked questions that people
have when they figure out that they're
interested in the Apple watch number one
what are the best apps for the Apple
watch and this could easily be its own
entire separate video but for now so my
favorites right now are Shazam which
just lets me ID a song with one tab on
the watch and deliveries which is
another favorite it's another one of
those things that I've gotten used to on
Android we're getting a notification
when a package gets delivered and then
actually some first party one so I
really like maps the turn-by-turn
directions function and the activity
tracker is very good if you're a fitness
person the Apple watch sport combined
with the fitness tracker is really good
and then of course there's things you
know like Instagram and Twitter but the
thing is these aren't really Apple watch
apps essentially they're iPhone apps
that happen to have an Apple watch
component to them so number two what's
the deal with these Apple watch apps and
why are they so slow here's the thing
Apple watch apps are not native what
this means is the components the
resources for the apps are not actually
stored on the watch they're stored on
your iPhone and when you tap to open
that app on your watch it streams and
moves all those resources to the watch
for you to open so that's why it can be
a little bit delayed a little bit slow
and can feel like it's lagging a lot and
you can store up to about 20 megabytes
of image resources on the watch for a
particular app but bottom line is
they're not native and that's why
they're slow fortunately there's a fix
for that thanks to the Apple watch gate
framework native Apple watch apps are
coming next year
should it have been that way to begin
with probably but at least they're
getting better number three is it
waterproof no but it is rated for ipx7
water resistance and essentially this is
just a precautionary measure
it means you can go out in the rain and
wear it outside and it's not a big deal
if it gets splashed but I there's been
videos on YouTube of it getting you know
water poured on it and being submerged
and even people taking showers with it
I wouldn't recommend those things even
though it technically survived but yeah
it's water resistant to a degree for how
is the battery life really it's actually
pretty good
in the hierarchy of modern smartwatches
that not including pebble the Apple
watch is pretty much up there it's I've
said in the full review it lasts about a
day and a half on battery I've never
killed it in a single day and I've
gotten pretty close to two days pretty
frequently and I've also got to test the
power reserve mode when I was traveling
today got on my flight put on power
reserve mode at about 97% six hours
later the flight was over and I check it
and I turn it back on and it's still at
97 percent so that was great it charges
in about an hour and a half to two hours
from empty and it does get a little bit
warm while charging but that's not a big
deal and you can also get a little bit
of extra battery out of your iPhone if
you don't check it as much since you're
using your watch number five does it
scratch yes it kind of does I have a
stainless steel version and I have like
one or two tiny hairline scratches on it
not a big deal my moto 360 also has a
couple of tiny hairline scratches on it
so that's not a big deal that's just the
way they are so number six what kind of
accessories are there for the Apple
watch it's an Apple product surely
there's going to be accessories and yes
there are there's a whole bunch first of
all there are some docs for it and these
are sort of alternative methods for
charging it since Apple's method isn't
exactly pretty you can get sort of a
larger more pretty version of a doc to
charge your Apple watch those I
understand actually the gold Apple watch
Edition even comes with its own custom
charging case then there are screen
protectors which I guess also makes
sense you want to keep it in pretty
decent condition you want to avoid those
scratches and force touch still works
everything still works with the screen
protectors on so that's fine and then
there are cases for the Apple watch you
don't need a case for the Apple watch
number seven is it true that there is a
mystery port on the Apple watch actually
yes there is there's a sort of a tiny
port a diagnostic port right behind
where the band clips in where it
actually does accept power so people are
sort of trying to come up with bright
ideas to take advantage of this one
company is actually building a new Apple
watch band with a battery built into it
to plug into that little tiny port sort
of a bright idea I'll leave a link to
that right below of that like button if
you want to check it out
and yeah that's sort of the idea it's
mostly still for Apple employees to
troubleshoot the watch number eight
what's good with force touch actually
force touch is really good especially in
the Apple watch mostly because the
vibration motor and the watch is so good
but it's sort of a more info button and
it's gotten pretty useful in the Apple
watch my favorite thing about it is just
long pressing on your notifications to
clear all notifications that's something
that I wish would come to Android wear
maybe we'll see that at Google i/o in a
couple of days but it's here to stay
it's in the new MacBook it's on the new
Apple watch and actually it's expected
to show up in the next iPhone as well so
force touch it works and it's pretty
good even though it has a terrible name
number nine what is the best combination
of band / size for the Apple watch
really it's all personal preference
you're just choosing a bunch of
materials for it my personal favorite
would be the 42 millimeter Space Gray
stainless steel with the leather loop I
actually think that leather loop looks
pretty badass so that brings us number
10 which is should you buy the Apple
watch and a lot of people's gut response
is either a heck no or maybe yes if you
own an iPhone and you want a smart watch
the Apple watch and the pebble are
really your only choices and at 349
bucks there are other smart watches at
this price and for the build the Apple
watch sport is at least worth that price
anything above the Apple watch sport the
functionality is exactly the same and
you're only paying for a difference in
materials they're paying for a leather
or Milanese band or stainless steel or
sapphire crystal those kinds of things
the craftsmanship is fine on the Apple
watch sport and if you can deal with
that I'd say yes but if you're going to
go above that really think about exactly
what materials are getting and if you
think spending five seven eight hundred
dollars or ten thousand dollars is worth
it on an Apple watch I would lean
towards no but if you're going to just
get into this for the first time Apple
watch sport is fine there you go guys
hope you enjoyed this video thank you
for watching and if you found it helpful
at all definitely share it for other
people who have questions about the
Apple watch hopefully this will answer
theirs as well again thanks for watching
and see you at Google i/o talk to you
the next one pace
you